we've got some breaking news uh now and
the court of appeal has rejected an
application from archie battersby's
family to appeal the ruling from the
high court which said he cannot be moved
to a hospice to die uh sky's adele
robinson's at the royal london hospital
in east london for us where archie uh
has been treated now for quite some
months and adele what does it mean from
here
well that's the big question isn't it as
you say the court of appeal has just uh
handed down their decision in which they
say that they are rejecting an
application to appeal against the
decision that was made by the high court
earlier today in the final paragraph of
that decision in that document it says
uh that the judgment deals
comprehensively uh with each of the
points he's talking about the judgment
earlier today with each of the points
raised on behalf of the parents we have
reached the clear conclusion that each
of her decisions that's the judges was
right for the reasons she gave it
follows that the proposed appeal has no
prospect of success and there is no
other compelling reason for the court of
appeal to hear an appeal so we will wait
to hear from the family now uh perhaps
there they might be considering another
legal avenue we don't know um just to
recap on what the high court judge said
earlier today and in which
the court of appeal has now agreed with
the judge there
agreed with clinicians and doctors here
at the hospital that it was in the best
interests of archie battersby to be
allowed to die here at the hospital and
not to be moved to a hospice the family
had argued that he should be allowed to
to be moved to a hospice to be given in
their words dignity and death and the
privacy that the family wanted for
themselves in uh the final moments of
archie's life now uh the judge at the
high court today said that
they she agreed with the clinicians and
that archie's condition was so unstable
that any transfer
could be risky uh that potentially he
could pass away on route to any hospice
and that would be despite
any um
intensive care equipment or specialist
or team or staff being there with him
now the judge also said that the final
arrangements that would be made here at
the hospital for archie would have up
there
as their central focus his best
interests and that would everything
would be put in place to allow him to
have a peaceful and private death with
his family
she also said in her final comments
that she described
the unconditional love
that archie's family had for him and
dedication to his uh to his well-being
describing it as a golden thread that
ran throughout this case now all today
the trust has said
that they would continue giving life
support until all legal issues have been
resolved
we wait to hear from the family as to
whether or not they will be taking uh on
other applications it sounds like
potentially uh the family we're just
getting in now are thinking of applying
or going to apply to the european court
of human rights uh waiting for company
confirmation uh it sounds as if they
potentially are at least considering
that but remember what happened here on
wednesday was the family applied to the
european court of human rights uh to
overturn a decision not to turn off
archie's life support and the european
court of human rights came back and said
that they would not interfere in a high
court's decision so we'll bring you more
uh on what
the next steps the next steps for
archie's family will be when we get it